here in the US it didn't take long for
the political implications of president
Trump's directive to surface Democrats
say they were not consulted or even
briefed about the airstrikes
Republicans say efforts are underway to
brief the entire Senate as soon as next
week and the president looking to calm
concerns addressed the nation Friday in
South Florida Paula Reid is traveling
with the president Paula good morning a
good morning Michelle president Trump
campaigned on a promise to end the u.s.
involvement in the Middle East and now
as he heads into 2020 he is trying to
convince his supporters that these
unprecedented strikes against Iran were
done in an effort to prevent future
conflicts we took action last night to
stop a war we did not take action to
start a war speaking from his Florida
Resort the president insisted
samso limini posed an immediate threat
to the United States Salamone was
plotting imminent and sinister attacks
on American diplomats and military
personnel but we caught him in the act
and terminated him a senior
administration official tells CBS News
the cabinet was in full agreement on the
strike but some Democratic lawmakers
complained the White House should have
consulted Congress about the
far-reaching decision I do not believe
the administration has gamed out how
very badly this could go for the US and
our interests I have yet to be fully
satisfied that the administration either
has a strategy that greatly concerns me
this is how you when nobody seeks war
end up in a war most Republicans praise
the president arguing he prevented
future attacks on Americans he is is
very resolved he's not going to allow
American interest to be attacked this
was an act of military conduct fully
justified and that's what happened the
president who campaigned on a promise to
end u.s. involvement in the Middle East
appeared to celebrate the strike at an
event in Miami
he was planning a very major
Tech and we got him Democratic
candidates on the trail criticized his
decision warning killing so limini could
provoke a regional war this is and was
an enormous escalation his actions now
put us on the path to another war a lot
of information has to still come out but
this is what I do know is this
president's had known Iran strategy the
president's national security adviser
Robert O'Brien says Iran has two options
they could decide like to continue to
escalate this conflict or they can come
to the negotiating table and sit down
with the United States
Dayna all right Paula Reid thank you
you